our far more impressive since they've
actually done the business a rather than
be political politically involved now on
the 7th of March this year president
tusk invite offered the United Kingdom a
Canada plus plus plus deal he said I
propose that we aim for a free trade
agreement covering all sectors and with
zero tariffs on goods and addressing
services and the three pluses he
mentioned were first continued
cooperation on security and crime second
joint programs on research innovation
Education and Culture and third he said
I'm determined to avoid the particular
absurdity that there should be
disruption of flight between the UK and
the EU and to do so we must start
discussions on this issue as soon as
possible sadly instead of saying yes as
long as it applies to the whole of the
UK the government turned down this
Canada Plus pass pass deal the main
reason they gave is that a free trade
area would involve more friction not
just in Northern Ireland but on all our
borders with the EU compared with being
in a customs
now proponents of this view notably the
Treasury and biz as well as remain
supporting lobbies the set of friction
caused by customs procedures will impose
huge costs cause lengthy delays disrupt
just-in-time supply chains and undermine
economic growth these assertions haven't
perceived the sort of critical challenge
which one might expect from our
commentary act after all these fears are
inevitably theoretical they're about
what might happen if we were in a free
trade area with the EU rather than a
customs of Union no one seems to have
asked what actually happens in practice
in countries which mean just such a
position if friction within free trade
areas is so awful while members of after
the EI NAFTA and the Asian free trade
areas lobbying to convert their free
trade agreements into customs unit they
don't seem to be to do so they don't
seem to find it as painful as the CBI
suggests it will be and they seem to
value the free trade agreements with
other countries which they would not
have been able to negotiate had they
been in a customs union and why is it
the comprehensive economic studies of
different forms of trade agreement find
no evidence that customer there's areas
outperform free trade areas on the
contrary they show that NAFTA for
example has been much more trade
creating than EU even then after the
free trade area EU is a customs union
with quite a lot of clusters as we show
in this paper many of the problems
ascribed to leaving the EU's customs
area are imaginable perfect union are
imagined and most of the rest are
exaggerated many are based on simple
misunderstandings of how it
national trade words for example
references to customs paperwork having
to be checked at the border after brexit
contract visions of lorry drivers
filling in forms which have been
laborious ly checked against the goods
in the back of their vehicle causing
delays and queues in fact virtually all
the customs declarations are made
electronically ahead of arrival at port
most consignments are cleared within
seconds of arrival a tiny percentage are
physically checked as a result of risk
assessment by HMRC computers or
intelligence information and such checks
may be carried out away from the borders
had importers premises or warehouses
moreover most checks relate to dutiable
goods illegal drugs or illegal
immigrants and are made on the basis of
risk intelligence risk or intelligence
information Anna Majesty's Customs and
Revenue do not expect any of these risks
to increase or new risks to emerge as a
result of bricks eat so they will not
require more checks than a present and
the same is true of checks on food
plants and animals coming into this
country in any case HMRC say and I quote
they will prioritize flow over
compliance to prevent congestion much
has been made of the importance of
just-in-time supply chains and rightly
so I was I think the first industry
secretary to try to promote these and
other Japanese management methods in the
UK in the 1990s but we should always
look at the facts Jake just in time
supply chains are not limited to the EU
they operate across customs borders
between a quarter and a fifth and motor
components imported into the UK come
from outside the EU delays in them would
have the same impact on production lines
as delays in those coming from the EU
moreover these supply chains seem to be
more resilient than often presented we
are warned that outside the customs
union especially as if
leave without a negotiated agreement
they would likely be congestion at
Calais backing up across the channel not
the m20 stopping or slowing incoming
vehicles so that just-in-time car plants
will grind to a halt we certainly don't
want to see such congestion but what
happens when congestion does occur
remember it occurs at present when
French fishermen blockade the port of
Calais when demonstrators surround the
channel entrance when immigrants burst
through the barriers and trains break
down with snow gums up the access roads
etc operations stack has been activated
on 211 days since 1998 and in the summer
of 200 2015 it was in operation for 23
near consecutive days with delays up to
35 hours yet I can find no report of
just-in-time factories interrupting
production they do appear to be
resilient and all credit to them of
course there are costs as well as
benefits of being in a free trade
agreement instead of a customs union
companies would have to make customs
declarations and declare the origin of
goods but the cost of these appear to be
wildly exaggerated just as benefit to
being able to negotiate our own trade
deals are systematically understated
Switzerland calculates that the cost of
these border processes that say and
remember their firms have to make
customs decorations and declare the
origin of their goods when they're
trading with the EU adds less than
Northpoint 1% to the cost of trade at a
fraction of the number theoretically
estimated by HMRC the suggestion by a
CBI and IOD that rules of origin add
several percent to the cost of trade are
particularly inflated they seem to be
unaware of a study by the WTO itself
suggesting that except on isolated
consignments the costs and I quote of
conforming to rules of origin are
negligible they seem unaware sorry and
that is before taking account oh the new
Rex self assistance
the assessment system introduced by the
EU
I hope this report will make government
and business look again at the facts and
reassessed their exaggerated concerns
about friction within free trade areas
or on WTO terms then we can get on and
enjoy the benefits of a brexit which
means brexit now I hand over to the rest
of the team or rather to Jacob to
marshal the rest of the team to hear
from practitioners my name is David odde
in 1991 my business partner and I
purchased the port of Bristol that was
immediately after the rather upsetting
70s and 80s when ports were known for
disruptive registered Dockers delays low
productivity etc etc since 1989 when
they got labour scheme was abolished the
port sector has invested huge sums in
productivity gains and I think it's fair
to say at the moment that the UK port
sector is as good as any port in Europe
it may sound strange and we don't often
get the spotlight shone upon us but the
fantastic growth in international trade
over the last 20 years would not have
been possible without that investment in
terms of our own little operation we
handle about 10 million tonnes of
various commodities two-thirds with the
rest
the world one-third with EU countries
customs procedures are smooth they do
not cause delays and inspections it is
all IT driven there are no quill pens we
pride ourselves for the sector in making
sure that our customers have no problems
getting through our respective ports and
I think it is fair to say that
throughout the UK where we deal both
with you origin and rest of the world it
is a pretty seamless activity obviously
there are concerns if we leave you leave
the single market in the customs union
and suddenly EU countries in the rest of
the world category we have a new customs
procedure being introduced to replace
the truth which the CVS system will come
into operation in March of 2019 this has
been commissioned for the moment and
HMRC should we leave and we have to
process all current EU documentation as
if it was the rest of the world the
capacity is that so in in short I think
as the port sector we feel we have
accomplished significant improvements in
making it frictionless as possible and
we're confident that will change in to
continue indeed David and now it's a
great pleasure to introduce again hands
mason thank you thank you my name is
Hans Martin I'm a custom specialist from
the Netherlands what surprised me and
looking at the discussion about wreck
cities all the things that were not
mentioned there is a opportunity to use
the existing custom system within the EU
and within the UK to make transparent
borders across the mossy and across the
Irish Sea and north/south on the island
of Ireland there is there is the transit
system that can provide the creations to
be made inland and at the premises of
the exporter and inland the premises of
the importer you don't need any stops at
the border
this system is available for 20 years
and it's not been discussed which is
unusual there's also a tracer system
which works very fine to follow
agricultural this veterinary goods and
phytosanitary goods it defines very
straight very clear what traders have -
where goods are traded from from one
such as certified
trailer to another all through Europe
that can be used by the UK after grexit
as well
and Peter nearly already mentioned the
REC system it's a very simple system
that is being introduced
globally also is in the UK to state in a
very simple way on your invoice the
origin of the goods and by the way the
UK is the country the Member State was
the most registration so far within the
European Union
I would like to mention one thing into
his drawl agreement if you look at nx3
of the Irish Protocol you'll see that
the government is proposing to introduce
reintroduce wet steps so there wiii be
reform called a UK movement certificate
with a wet stamp that will have to be
used by 'man exporters to prove that
goods are of the EU or UK origin or have
been important I have not seen a wet
stamp since 1992 thank you very much
[Applause]
trade my day job for all the guys I've
been involved in the discussions about
the European has been building up
consumer goods company which now trades
with 85 countries across the world and
moves about 2,000 containers a year from
one place to another so I attentive
experience of what it's actually like to
operate inside the WTO type of regime
which actually covers about 80% of all
the container movements that we're
responsible for me and I have to say
that our experience bears out everything
we've heard so far from the speakers on
the platform here and what's in this
excellent document done under
difficulties we have amount of the days
and told us we have is really minimal
the retail world in which I operate is
not an easy one but one of the problems
we really don't have is not being able
to get hold of the goods that we need
them and to rely on customs
reinstatement places pretty quickly so
that we don't get held up we are in fact
in this one sort of industry where just
in time is just as important as it is in
the car in the street
we're running big promotions and can't
get the stock we're in trouble
but we don't have to
and this is why I think this paper is so
portable but I think this country has
been scared into assuming that if we
have no deal for the dream it doesn't go
through that were in front of Armageddon
with difficulties and I think that one
of the major difficulties that people
are scared about is a trade between the
UK and Europe would be severely
disrupted and all I can say is that my
experience suggests that that will not
be the case it does seem to me they've
been making difficult decisions in this
country to do so on the basis of false
information it's exactly the bomb where
to go back and the clarity the dis
document put forward and the
explanations and and detail it provides
about how relatively easy it is to get
this right I think is very important so
I very strongly support this document
it's in front of you today
[Applause]
thank you and no thank you son Boyd and
children have managed Simon Boyd
managing director of their with steel
John Wetton solace we were founded in
1919 and in a hundred years of well near
hundred years of trading we've explored
to over 140 countries across the world
we've got throughout UK and despite a
single market we've had nothing but
difficulties in trading with an EU to to
protectionism the customs union has been
very bad for us along with the single
market these of help businesses like US
bank and we face significant tariff
barriers to get enough goods into India
and the Far East you know some South
American
in places and areas with Middle East and
we what was very difficult places in the
world was a safe way of designing we're
manufacturing great jobs in the UK using
British steel and exporting that product
all the way ranked across the world with
four times one is for international
trade to give me some kind of idea of
what we do and we're a medium-sized
business and we are really concerned
that we are not going to get the clean
breaks in that businesses like us needs
and not all businesses in the CBI are
singing from the same hymn sheet I'm on
the CPI
I said the manufacturing Council and I
can't go over the European Union quick
enough are clearly enough and I'm really
worried what's going on in government
today with Prime Minister's plans would
be a complete betrayal for what we about
what fought and fought for for many many
years
thank you very much thank you see beyond
the CBI I feel slightly intimidated by
the qualifications of everybody else
on this panel my in a much more mundane
only many years ago before I was a
member of parliament I did operate
businesses across borders
some of them much more difficult than
the EU border across the canada-us
and as a result when I listen to the
sorts of fatigue we are having about our
future border arrangements I just
thought they were out of the realm of
what I considered to be anything like
practical or sensible so I'm really
pleased to be here today to support this
plate but which has Peter Lily's
characteristic clarity simplicity of
focus in its addressing of the problem
now the premise behind it all I guess is
that a free trade agreement is much much
more important than a customs union may
be the best demonstrator of this so that
was the back of people's mind when he
talked about being a minister that dealt
with Uruguay around since the Uruguay
Round came into effect we have actually
been less successful at exporting the
European Union the many members of many
countries that are not members of your
opinion you know not just for words like
America as well we've had a much more
successful record and so for them the
customs barrier around European unit the
common external tariff barrier was not
not a problem and this is also true I
think just looking through the document
on page 12 I think it is the custom
problems of crossing a customs barrier
and not even not even significant in the
just-in-time spirit as you see there the
large amount of the just-in-time
provision for our industries comes from
outside the European Union now let alone
before so we've seen massive
overestimation massive exaggeration of
the problems of dealing with a modern
custom system and I stress modern custom
system I mean custom systems in the last
20 30 years
got faster and faster more more
efficient
cheaper and cheaper hardly surprising
your mobile phone today works much
better than it did but years ago and so
there's your Costco system and this is
this is this is an answer not just
through the technically economic
problems but to the political problems
the answers of the Northern Ireland
issue which you heard that you talked
about a few weeks ago is similarly
straightforward as so this paper goes
right to the heart of two of the largest
problems that the government imagines it
sees in the deal it will deal with
Northern Ireland and it will deal with a
primary friction if there is a friction
in our traffic and what it shows very
very clearly if there are practical
answers to the issues of leaving
European Union which do not require us
to give up our sovereignty do not
require us to give up our freedom do not
require us to stay inside the customers
using forever but actually allow us to
be a free country that's me thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen there's now some
time for questions but the message that
you must have heard so clearly this
morning is that there is another way and
that's really important because there's
been this feeling that all that can be
done is what the government's suggesting
there's nothing else it's this way or no
way but actually there is a well thought
through practical and already available
set of systems that could be used and I
think that's the key message from these
great experts who are dealing with these
matters on a daily basis so thank you
for listening to that and I'm now very
happy to open it up to questions if
there are any so who's going to go first
you want me to go to the BBC you first
well thank you very direct and
straightforward question the ERG does
not have a collective use I've always
made clear and people come to their own
decisions on leadership but actually
what we're seeing from the government is
a deliberate decision not to deliver a
proper exit but we have a government led
by Romania's that want to keep us tied
in to the European Union as tightly as
possible the Prime Minister in a
statement on Friday afternoon said this
was the deal she had always wanted and
the deal that she's got is not a proper
brexit so that's the thing to bear in
mind as as for letters patience is a
virtue virtue is a grace etc we shall
see whether letters come into time and
there's a meaningful vote as well and
we'll see what happens with that to a
government that seems to marinated its
competency supply partners however I can
try and keep questions for the rest of
the panel rather than for me if anyone
has questions for me we can gave those
apps privately afterwards
well firstly I hope you're right about
try Stan I hope you're right a material
and so I thought that's what happens but
it isn't by itself enough there's also
the question of regulatory compliance as
well and that is very important to our
future businesses it's we are likely to
be in the lead and things like
artificial intelligence genetics and so
on we cannot be a world leader in those
industries if somebody else writes the
regulation is false
similarly it is not just a Northern
Ireland border issue that determines
when we get out the customs union it is
also the question of the customs
arrangements the so-called future
customs arrangements that the government
proposed many people think and the hands
may want to talk about this and many
people think this is either impossible
or take five or ten years to put in
place that is also unacceptable so it's
a great great users will write that that
the premises will need to move on the
Norn island issue as I hope you've done
some time ago but I also want to see a
new another
well indeed as I mentioned these
existing systems can be used ready
they're ready to be used
they gave witness to the House of
Commons and I said there that did the
transition period of 2020 we can have
all these customs formalities up and
running that's no problem but we should
start today thank you
one of your colleagues City Hall said
the front row knows that crew is
entirely the wrong word indeed it's a
rather silly word because what I have
done and what others have done is used
the democratic process within the
Conservative Party to say we have no
confidence in the leader of the
Conservative Party this is not an
illegitimate process it's one set out in
the rules and this type of language is a
vague language is rather damaging to
political debate because it tries to see
things in terms that are not realistic
they're not true it is just like a
general election in a way that is a
legitimate means of changing leader and
using legitimate means is completely
proper and people will then make their
decision through 47 want to come with me
or not now I may find that they don't or
that they don't do it today but they do
it when we've got the
that is a decision for them in politics
you have to set out your store you have
to say what you believe in
and you then see whether people agree
with me or not fortunately in a
democracy it is not given to insist that
people follow you that's one of the
great virtues of our system I better
come to the other cool manga sitting in
the front row I've always admired
captain Manning David Davis so I didn't
hear the
when you say it's late in the day all of
us before last like 14 15 months ago I
was I signed off a policy report on
future customs arrangements and on North
Island and actually they covered many of
the issues that this report leads to
what this report does is knock down the
arguments against against what was
called max fact the accelerated and
knocked down the arguments against
having a a practical and sensible
arrangement in Northern Ireland so it's
not late in the day yes I do hope that
once we once Parliament turns down they
can't proposal we return to these
sentences Terry what means yes I would
hope that if Parliament turns down what
the government is proposing then they
will go back to the you and say can we
take up the offer you made on the 7th of
March and negotiate on that basis as
long as it covers the whole United
Kingdom they will either say yes or no
if yes good it can be done very briefly
free trade deals normally take a long
time because countries start with 10,000
different tariffs and 10,000 different
regulations and they have to equate them
we start you know have to get rid of
10,000 tariffs and get them down to zero
we start with zero tariffs we want to
end up with zero tariffs that can't take
more than 10 minutes the other thing
that is required is equating or
rendering equivalent your regulations
and removing those which are an obstacle
to trade we start with identical
regulations that can't take very long
the main thing therefore is to negotiate
an agreement as to what happens if one
or other side changes their regulations
that exists in Canada and other type
deals that will complicate it but
doesn't take a huge time so it could be
done in the time available if not we
leave on World Trade Organization term
and then we're in a much stronger
position actually to negotiate such a
deal with the EU just as Canada was on
WTO terms when it negotiated its deal
with the EU better to do it before but
if not trying to
we've been getting the telegraphed we've
been very silent so far I'm sorry
there's questions have nothing to do
with today's report but I will answer
any questions anybody has on other
matters later on say would you like to
ask a question about the report or Sligo
to the prime minister said yesterday
that what she said is what she said
which is not going to change it so I
think that's two hypothetical and yes I
think we are in a house of God there's
more joy in heaven over one sinner that
repenteth than over ninety-nine just men
who have no need of repentance so let us
hope that everybody coalesces on a
sensible view
I refer to the answer I gave to the
Telegraph a moment ago if anyone if
anyone wants to talk to me about other
matters I'll talk them later let's stick
to the report yeah any other no yeah
well we'll come back to you later and
we'll have people who want to ask
questions about the report anyone want
to ask question about the reforms yes
please
our failures the answer I gave to
Channel five News to Telegraph know
right anymore sorry speed with what's
Carly sayin
though there are a whole range of no
deals from a straight absolute no deal
with no rain from so ever through a
bare-bones no deal much more likely
through a no deal which included
implementation period and so on so it
all possible
[Music]
chief is going to be replaced by
whatever is CES in PDF and hopefully
that's all on time and that will have
the capacity to handle all the extra
declarations that will need to be made
when EU trade becomes third party trade
I wasn't quite sure what the final
sentence of your Center Oh what
no no I'm that that that that's fine
it's it's not that we need new
technology we need to take advantage of
the opportunities that exist in existing
union customs code for us trading with
them and our own customs code which we
obviously free to alter for others
trading with us I refer you to a
statement that was made at the recent
conference of Klee cat which is an
organization that comprises 19,000 firms
across Europe dealing with logistics
customs and so on and how will they
handle 80% of customs transactions and
the Chairman is that all the ingredients
to ensure a smooth exit process of the
UK from the EU and which allow almost
frictionless trade after the exit are
already available so we have to make use
of them
[Music]
and this custom system that we've been
referring to is universal it's the same
all over Europe so it applies to the
Dover internet we should not have any
custom delays at Dover ok there's no
space 5 meter high fences 5 kilometres
inland because of illegal immigrants to
White Cliffs of Dover so the so trade
should be making it's fulfilling its
customs obligation inland from Cologne
to Coventry you can drive without any
formalities and the same can be applied
to Northern Ireland we don't need any
infrastructure at the border that can
help solve the Backstairs one more
question yes please
well she is not alone in having said
that the Chancellor said it and mr.
Verret assent
I have repeatedly asked the Chancellor
and his officials for the point in the
WTO or World Customs organization rules
that require that they keep promising to
give it to me and they never do so I
assume that they are over interpreting
what the organization's rules the rules
certainly mean that you can't
discriminate between different countries
or different suppliers but you can have
different procedures at different ports
some hoards are open 24 hours a day
others not and that sort of thing and
say might have different procedures on
the Irish border from what you have on
the Dover Calais approach so I'm afraid
you will have to ask her what's the text
she's referring to this really is the
last question
yes please
I'm going to say once again that's
really the wrong type of language we've
heard clearly from the Prime Minister
and this is an area where I completely
agree with that
let us use moderate language about these
serious political matters and nights of
the Long Knives conjures up all sorts of
unpleasant images in particular dare I
say coming from German television is
entirely unsuitable for modern political
discourse very much for coming there
will be opportunities to speak to
members of the panel now and I'm
extremely grateful for your attendance
this paper really does put the
alternative case and it's a very strong
one thank you
[Applause]